let's jump to this story we got this
from timcast.com indiana legislature
overrides governor's veto to enact
transgender sports regulations the aclu
has already challenged the bill in court
citing title ix
legislators in indiana enacted a bill
requiring students to compete on sports
teams that correlate with their
biological sex minutes later the aclu
filed a lawsuit arguing the bill is a
form of gender-based discrimination that
violates title ix
and
i'll just say
i think the aclu is right
i don't think they're right um
culturally i think they're right legally
and that's something i've long talked
about
you can't have gender segregation under
the 1964 civil rights act under title ix
so the arguments that were made for
ending racial segregation make sense the
arguments for ending uh gender
segregation don't make sense but there's
a legal precedent that doesn't care
about the distinction so this is what's
happening in schools now so basically
this bill is trying to say like
look i'm going gonna put it this way for
everybody who's not familiar with what's
going on or who maybe doesn't understand
there is a female pro skateboarder came
out as trans
kept competing against females
then you get male skateboarders who say
that they're actually women and then
they compete against females
it only flows in one direction this is a
big part of the problem this is what
these bills are trying to address if if
we need to create a new league a new
division for for trans athletes then
sure maybe that's a solution but just
eliminating the women's division makes
no sense now the aclu is arguing you
can't have gender segregation
i think the issue is the law says that
i'm trying to understand exactly what
the aclu is saying because
i mean the aclu the people tweet out the
men have periods right they're they're
they're basically nuts right yeah
they're nuts so here's the issue
from a legal standpoint i think they
have a correct argument
legally correct but not like an actually
what's the right way to say it
justifiable right right right just
justifiably like ethical morally or
ethical yeah it's a better way to put it
the 1964 civil rights act you can't
discriminate against a person in public
accommodation based on national origin
sex gender blah blah whatever race
so from that we were like okay
no more you know white restroom and
black restroom it's all gonna be the
same
but even though the 1964 civil rights
act includes gender we never end gender
gender segregation for obvious reasons
men and women are different
okay so on the precedent side you are
saying that it is correct because of the
civil rights act and how it was enacted
i i think people need to understand that
the
that these laws are not that when when
we try to create a logical formula right
for for a cultural problem that is
nuanced and and is experience is
experienced in a gradient way
you will have issues like this right so
we're basically saying that we do
actually need laws that segregate women
from men in terms of these types of
things whether it comes to sports or
yeah any of these is that a hot day i
don't know i mean that feels pretty
natural to say yeah well so we had we
had i think it was delano squires who
was on we were talking about this and he
was like
you can't you you can travel all over
the world and see the differences
between men and women are like uniform
right differences between different uh
groups of people in different areas you
know are different as well so the issue
with race is that it's not a good
reason
to segregate somebody like you say this
you know this guy's white and this guy's
black well one dude is italian and five
foot five and one guy's you know swedish
and six foot five i mean race is not
the issue right now so so for like uh
mma we do weight categories and things
like that right for
segregating based on race for a bathroom
that makes no sense but gender
experienced all over the world by every
single human being 99.8 of the time is
the same
there's a reason why we separate it i
mean there's a variety of cultural
reasons and then actual physical reasons
but the 1964 civil rights act doesn't
include any of that
so there would have to be this would
have to be addressed one of the one of
the issues at play is that they have um
they they'll they allow segregation at
certain universities in like for gender
segregation when it's like a woman in
computers program there's a lawsuit it
was something like this
some guy sued saying you can't have a
woman in computers program because that
is discriminatory against males
the school said we have a men in
computer program and the courts ruled
that so long as they offer the same
opportunities to both it's not actually
discriminatory and i'm like wouldn't
that precedent apply to national origin
religion or race as well
that was what we got rid of when we
ended segregation so how is it different
when it comes to gender under the same
law
i'm a lawyer right and what i find
interesting about these types of
conversations is that it shows very
clearly that the law doesn't have an
answer for everything
these types of laws obviously with you
know the subject of transgenderism when
these laws were written down that wasn't
an issue you know so it poses all of
these new new problems that now the law
has to respond to needs to answer to and
it doesn't know how to
and i think with something like this the
way that we've always dealt with that
was morality so you have certain norms
in society that dictate okay well
obviously in this case we find the
segregation or the differentiation of
certain groups justified because that's
just the way it is there is no better
argument really for it or that's the way
it should be because we have a shared
idea of what is right and what is wrong
in society and therefore you know that
problem kind of solves itself
but now we're looking to all these we're
looking to these problems and we're
saying oh we need to create laws around
it and often you just make more of a
mess around obviously i think we
probably need to codify
that we can segregate on basis of sex
when i'm saying gender i'm literally
talking about biological sex gender and
sex but it's the civil rights laws are
about gender they're talking about
gender do they mention 1964 it says sex
i'm using i'm using gender the classical
way right to refer to the biological
differences between men and women the
obvious way so you want to you want to
discriminate in so far as you don't want
to put a naked woman around a bunch of
naked men that are in heat yes right in
heat yeah
that's a family friendly dog putting it
yeah yeah so discrimination is massively
important if you can't just make a
discrimination if you can't discriminate
against a guy running at you with a
knife and a guy standing on a corner not
looking at you you're going to die so
you need to discriminate i'm not going
to pretend i'll have all the answers i'm
just going to say that
culture is everything
when we we
enshrined the 1964 civil rights act i
think we did some tremendous good ending
segregation was was was right
segregation was wrong
and
why didn't we end sec why didn't we end
sex sex sex segregation why were we like
okay now there can't be different
restaurants for different races but you
can still separate schools and public
accommodations for different you know
you can have ladies night you do all
these things because culturally
everybody was okay with it so there was
no need to change it now we have the
rise of this woke cult and they're
exploiting this law and our culture for
not addressing these things
i think the real intent is just to
destroy yeah you know confuse right yeah
demoralize yeah constantly confusing
yuri besmanov says yes well you talked
about on twitter was today or the other
day about a civil war in this country i
mean it feels to me like we're at a
place when i was growing up versus now
we are at a place where there is no
coming back for some of these people on
the left that some of these ideas that
have spawned out of their mouths that
they write about and they talk about are
so radical and so different from
anything that has ever been talked about
in human history that i don't see a way
that we come back i mean we're already
in a civil war of ideas in this country
civil war of ideas in the west i hope
that it doesn't get violent but it seems
like we're headed towards some sort of
national divorce you have people who are
fine with butchering savagely killing
babies after they are born and calling
it helping the woman i'm supposed to
live in a society with people like that
it doesn't you know
this the conversation on abortion keeps
coming up uh
someone some news outlet i don't know
wrote an article saying that i was a
a conservative who was obsessed
with late term abortion which never
which never happens
simply because i said hey look democrats
are trying to pass late-term abortion
legislation why
you're obsessed with it
it never happens tim why are you talking
about it i'm like
i'm talking about it because you just
tried to legalize it yeah i don't
understand like you said we're going to
legalize i said why i'm not obsessed i'm
asking you why you did this thing this
is their little trick right they do that
all the time with these types of things
they say oh never happens but then when
it happens to good things oh yeah so
that's that's just i think the
but when it happens it's a good thing
yeah yeah well this is that's the crazy
thing too and they're talking about
tucker carlson all of these democrats
talk about immigration as a means of
maintaining political power then tucker
carlson gets angry about it and they're
like he's pushing conspiracy theories
it's like what
this they they do to trump all the time
or they would trump would read the news
and then he'd be like you see this thing
that's going on it's a very interesting
medicine and then the media would be
like trump makes up medical
misinformation he's dangerous and it's
like i read that in techcrunch yeah
trump like watches the news
repeats it and they call him a liar
i love it when politics is that easy
when he mentioned inner city
unemployment and they said it was mostly
false but it was it was like a verbatim
quote from bernie sanders which was
mostly true
incredible how they do this i mean
that's those man on the street i've done
a lot of man on the street videos on
with prague or you you know check them
all out but you know where you go and
tell someone you say hey this is what
the what the republicans or the
conservatives are saying and then it
turns out that oh that was actually the
left yeah that was actually the left
that was actually the democrats i mean
we did one about the history of the
democrat party i did on hollywood
boulevard a couple years ago going and
asking people and saying you know who
started the kkk all these things they
all think it's republicans when it's
really democrats i mean you can quote
these people verbatim and they will
still tell you that you're a liar and
that everything you say is untrue you
know that's a strategy michael malus had
a good tweet uh he said i'll start
believing that you care about kids lives
when you care about the ones that joe
biden took or something that affect and
i don't remember the exact quote from
michael but i'll put it this way i'll
believe that these any of these people
care about kids lives when they have a
national news cycle condemning barack
obama for the children he killed
including the american citizen citizens
but you know namely abdulrahman
al-awlaki a 16-year-old american citizen
that obama killed right where was the
big news cycle in fact when luke
rydkowski was at i think it was the i
think was a 2012 dnc i think it was the
dnc and he and another uh reporter for
weir change asked these these
personalities about the drone
assassination of abdul rahman al-awlaki
an american 16 year old
someone i think it was charlie gibbs i'm
not sure said he should have had a
better father they don't care
they don't care about who they blow up
or kill they they're using political
wedge issues and that's why they never
offer any real solutions any of these
problems that's why they're like
background checks it's like dude we
already have those right what are you
talking about right there's no gun show
loophole i mean yeah it's it's nonsense
it it it's the weirdest thing like every
time i go to buy a gun i got to fill up
my little background check for them i
think they're i the the only thing i can
do is if i want to steal man their
argument is that they're talking about
like in west virginia you can sell up
into a family member or you know a
private sale you're still legally
responsible for that you'll go to prison
if this person isn't legally allowed to
have it so if they've done drugs if
they're if they're depressed like you
can get in trouble for we have those
laws
but they're like common sense gun reform
i'm like what does that mean well if
it's not saying anything if it's a white
person then it's white supremacy's fault
is a shooter if it's a if it's anyone
else of any other race it's gun control
all these things are is a tool that the
left can use to bludgeon their opponents
i mean all of these things they don't
care about any of it it's just a tool to
get their way it's just crazy that you
see that dude in waukesha
you know he rams this this parade he's
got black nationalist stuff on his
facebook and they're like nah nahs he's
not political no it's like
come on dude yeah someone the other
night mentioned that although these i
don't know if you call them psychopaths
or this aberration of american society
are using leftist tactics it's not
actually the american left the american
left and right are still relatively sane
and somewhere towards the center but
you've got this weird like pseudo
communist fascist uh probably
psychoactively
dampened group of people that are
ripping themselves apart and screaming
and busting stuff up that i i wonder i
wonder about this i wonder about the
medication rates among conservatives
versus liberals
there was a poll i was reading that said
uh liberals are more likely to
experience mental illness do you ever
see this one
now the left argued that it's not that
they have more mental illness it's that
republicans don't go to the doctor
and i'm like i don't need to go to
doctor i'm all good or it's like i'm a
big strong man i don't even know the
doctor but i don't that data doesn't
show that you can speculate all you want
i don't see it in the data all i know is
the data says
liberals the left are more likely the
further you go left the more mental
illness they are the more deep in the
city you live the more mentally ill you
may become that's what happened to me i
mean you're in la right now are you guys
noticing have you noticed like your own
mind in that city getting broken or yeah
or what i mean i stay away from a lot of
the city stuff i live kind of in a i
live out in burbank if people familiar
again with la no it's kind of outside of
la outside the city outside of hollywood
so i try to keep to myself and my dog we
kind of hang out a lot so but i know a
lot of people who live in that city and
before when i first moved to l.a and did
a lot of stuff in hollywood did a lot of
stuff in beverly hills all that kind of
stuff it was destroying my mind yeah the
brake dust a lot of it's the brake dust
off the car pads the brake pads it's
it's more fine than carbon i think more
fine than carbon dioxide maybe not
carbon dioxide but more fine than like
soot and it goes through the avioli in
your lungs right into the bloodstream
and makes just massive hypertension and
depression let's not forget all the
fluoride in the water that's right
you guys you guys have i tried that no
no the first time i came here like this
or the first time i drank a glass of
water which is six days ago because this
is my first time in the u.s the first
thing i said to him is this tastes like
pool like a pool yeah it's got chlorine
that's the chlorine probably yeah well
but it tastes completely different yeah
no our our water is very filtered but no
if you don't in your water you sure
go check it out dutch waters i swear
it's very filtered it's filtered thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there is a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and we'll
see you all there